For, uh, you know,
fast rising stars that are a rising
because of their beastliness in there,
knock out power. It's not uncommon
for them to not train Jujitsu. Right.
We've seen plenty of them,
you know what I mean?
How crazy would it be if Zingano
actually trained Jujitsu? Right.
And fell knowing at the time for that.
You know what I mean?
We don't know what he does.
Right. We don't know if he, they,
she just hit, you know what I mean? It's
probably not going to have a center,
but how loud,
if he didn't say he just,
he just went to Danaher's and just
fell in love with John Danaher.
They just became best friends now would
be any jumped in. Imagine how good,
you know what I mean?
With Jujitsu, he's like,
how old is you could only survive
with knock out power for so long.
You know what I mean? After a while
you're going to be getting clips easily.
Tail Hook guys were killing this show,
but talking over each other like this.
Yeah. You're, you're 100% right. You know
what I'm saying? Is eventually no matter,
no.
We see it over and over again.
No matter how Beasley you are and how
powerful you are with those punches,
eventually you're going to get clipped,
right? You're going to go down.
So eventually you might have to switch
your strategy to instead of going out
there and just trying to knock a dude out
to going out there and try and take it
to town and submit this month,
here we go. Well, he's so powerful.
If he had good wrestling
skills, holy shit, you're
gonna find out. Right? Exactly.
Says this is what if that has a
thing he's like with wrestlers,
don't you think that you have to
learn it at a really young age? Well,
George Saint Pierre didn't, right? Oh,
good head.
Damn.
Damn. Look how giant he lives.
So shit dude, he's so big.
So big. It's so dangerous. Shit.
Oh my goodness.
Come on man.
He's incredible.
Did he blew his ACL, MCL, LCL. Something's
wrong with his leg or maybe not.
Dude and cane is one of the best of
all time. That's how good in Ghana was.
Damn. He got through that block. Fuck.
He got through it and
this
guy I've ever seen,
and it wouldn't have been a surprise
if in Ghana was super cautious,
maybe two rounds of being super cautious.
We wouldn't be that surprise. Right?
Chill out Bro. But the fact
that he fucking threw down
like this, boom, he went,
oh
you almost like forearm.
You got forearmed in the first.
The first
she was his name. It, no, let's see.
This again.
Never got hit anywhere.
Oh Jesus.
Oh shall we say.
Oh Wow.
Everybody missed it.
We all missed it for Kina.
Let's be real damn
back injury. And I said this,
that Lcl, MCL, blow MCL.
Right then when it's bent this way,
when it comes to, that's all of them.
That's MCL. How old is he now? I don't
know. But he's a weathered whatever he is.
Shit turns 37
I wouldn't even fight.
And you could only take so many wars.
Each war is significant in your life.
Like each one took some of your
life and eventually that's it.
You can't, you already, you went to
five crazy wars. That's not that.
That's what Tom or that ended that
way. Well, you know what it is, man.
I think guys that are that
championship caliber like cane,
their mind is so ferocious that
their body is almost like a spaceship
reentering. It's missing tiles and
it starts fuck a chicken apart.
They're so powerful in terms of
their ability to teach driving.
They just keep driving and then
the knees go in, the neck goes in,
the back goes and then you deal with
these physical realities of the body that
you're giving.
It's still there.
I know the middle of that.
I'm in the middle of trying to come back.
You know what I mean?
Right now since my shoulder,
it's been six months since my shoulder
surgery had my bicep reattached to my
shoulder,
had knee surgery about 10 months ago.
That's still not 100% like it's still,
they're not red.
They're still 20 when they good Roland
with I'm rolling with the hunting 30
pound blue belts and shit
that he read write about shit.
The last three weeks I've been rolling
with some little blue belts that I got to
be able to have like 50 pounds on
him and have total control. You know,
like at this point,
you know what I mean?
I'm still a little weird for franchisors
are blown ACL for Kate. Well,
I mean it definitely is a blown knee for
cane, but Francis, when's your fight?
Because like when Francis was
coming after him and he clipped him,
he definitely clipped him with
that forearm behind the neck date,
eat or Honda persist. That's a
nightmare. That's 100% for him.
That's a nightmare outcome.
100% cause Francis as little case
I just clipped and knocked down.
Do you want to hear that? They say,
yeah. What did they have to say? Yeah,
give me some volume,
but I look at the tits on him.
I don't hear anything. Good
job, Jamie. There it goes.
Okay.
I mean he believes it now.
He did, but I liked it the way
he was moving in on them, man.
I mean he really did look,
talk us through it again
on that Land Rover. At that forum did
the forum later in the back of his neck,
maybe your hands was shit,
blah, blah. You know what, man?
I'm going to rethink what I said.
I'm going to rethink it. I know.
You see I stopped. I thought I
saw his forearm clip. His neck.
That's not where he blows it.
Wait, no, no, no, no trouble.
What do you think you did
hit him with that? No,
he kind of fell though before that.
No, Jane goes, that's what it is.
Yes.
I'll just and shit.
The thing is he's so heavy handed.
I think you might be correct,
but I do think that he connected with
his neck or the guys this heavy handed.
Hold on a second. That no damage on his
shoulder. That was nothing. Nothing,
nothing. Nothing. Nothing. Yep.
Nigos that because you're right.
You're right. You're right. I
was wrong. I thought it was,
I thought it hit his neck. It did
not hit his neck. It hit his back.
Right shoulder.
Right elbow was clear.
There is the total up. Here we go.
Holy Shit Dude. He was throwing around.
He's a freak for it to saint ghetto.
You're right.
That's a defensive line right there.
Okay.
A middle linebacker,
right? Well, he's not done.
See the thing about this guys, he, he
hasn't been finding for very long though.
Even though he loses to steep. Bain
has that, that timid and scared Lewis.
He says so little mileage. What
does it say about his name? Hold on.
That's how it happened. I know it
wasn't the result you're looking for.
It will take some time, but how soon
might we see you back in, you know,
they're more calm and relaxed.
Ready to go.
This why this war. So breaking.
Everyone was going to happen
or it's the worst. Very classy.
Yeah. Came very classy. You know,
never bitter.
How weird is it?
The Fox and this one,
he's not even talking about his knee
thing is in retire. Things here. Retire.
No need to apologize. I know I speak
for you upstate fans around the world,
by the way. How good. How good is Jon
Anik? He's a bass. That's the best.
It's such a bummer to lose that wonderful
that Jon Anik is so good. I love John.
I'm so impressed with him. Like when
I worked with him, he's the best.
He's so like, he's such a
good commentator. Here's
a little thing right here.
The first thing I'm going
to make sure it ESPN MMA,
like let's look at this was
the shoulders was the, was
maybe an uppercut uppercut might've
landed right there. Ooh, my right there.
Right there. Right away. Upper
cut might've sat them down.
The opera cut mine high
iron cheese. God, here we go
again. Here we gotta go. So nothing
driving so far. Not Right. No, no.
You sell.
Can I redeem myself?
Okay, let's see. You are different anger.
I'm like cheese. Ice missed
it. That was a legit,
it's a legit,
when I was getting too close,
he blew his knee out for sure
because the uppercut watching
Sandown
cause is what's important.
Matt Taibbi has a fantastic article out
right now about one of the problems with
society today is that people look at
the news like they look at sports.
Like someone asks me write about things.
You have to know everything.
But it's a great article.
Matt Taibbi.
This is a perfect example of four guys
who are lifelong martial artists and we
both went both ways. I was like, you're
right, and then we saw it again and like,
you're right. That's how you're
supposed to look at Shit. Yeah.
That's how you supposed to let them lines.
It
can't be attached. Certain fights
he gets stopped early. Okay.
Tj Answer Huda.
I thought it was stopped early due.
I've talked to people that say they
didn't think it was stopped early and I'm
like, all right, hey, I'll listen
to me. Listen, he clipped him,
but I felt like when I watch it that
you got to give a guy a chance to fight
more, but especially on that,
hey, you out in the NFL,
when they review plays,
they review them and one of the most
important things about reviewing a play is
that you have multiple
angles. Yeah, it's all
three angles. They keep going back
to the first angle we didn't get,
we didn't get a good enough angle
because that right hand was like a ghost
writing. I didn't see it. You guys
saw it. I didn't see it so exciting.
With shit like that is going on and
the UFC truck is the best in the world.
Like mark tell the grotto and
all those dudes back there,
Anthony Giordano and the whole crew,
they're always moving. Mark Delicate.
Rodney Rodney motherfucker.
He works,
he figures out what the replay shine
love him. He's like, I didn't know that.
I didn't know that. I fucking
love that dude. He's the
shit. So He's, he does like,
he'll like pick the play by play angles.
He'll pick lecture and cause he talks
about fights because he knows. Yeah,
Todd Feldman made bank off a fucking
Francis by the way. He did big bank. Damn.
I'm telling you dude, if that guy keeps
learning and it seems like he got out,
he had a weird spot.
But you know what I really like about
that weird spot that he got into? Yep.
He was honest about it. He said, I
carried over fear from my last fight. Oh,
a guy who can look at himself that
honestly plus his ego got out of control
cause he's not going to dude's
out and then that's a good thing.
He know. He said that an interview
like even as his ego, just coaches,
like he just thought he was
bigger than the game. Right.
But the on how bold and now he fucking
just knocked out Cain Velasquez before
that. He murked fucking homeboy.
I mean Chris Blades, hi.
Can't remember the name.
He looked,
he looked like he was in a
different weight category.
He's the, based on your
strength, you know,
it is like the future is an
athlete that really at 265 pounds,
it doesn't have to gain any weight.
It doesn't have to lose anyway.
Oh they're going to show it to us again.
The the future is and can we talk
who hasn't deterred debut a Fox.
Cain gets knocked up by G
jds. Jesus Christ, ESPN.
He gets knocked up by Francis and he
took that jab right there to Frances
Frances Clifton with a hard job to
be to understand what you're saying.
Okay. That's a legit point.
I just wanted to be like, oh,
100% some quick fast and I want to
say that again. I want to do that.
How fast he is. Back up just a wee
bit. Yes. Just out of the play.
This over and over. Let's look. Let's
look at this. The exchange kitchen.
We're sweet C he hits him.
Nothing fucking right hand,
right upper cut shovel.
It's a shocking struggle.
Can we get slow mo is that he hits him
with a rock and then you need the shush
of the faith instead of,
he said, try one more time.
I think his knees. Okay. Right
now. Not Hell's now. Ooh,
wait a minute. That's why I came to him
and he goes, I came in to close too soon.
He's so powerful. Watch this.
Watch that Shit Jamie. Just play,
play, pause, play, pause,
play, pause, play punks,
directv guy like it's a VCR
in the nineties this angle,
it looks like we're trying to get a tick
in the nineties for sure in Ghana is a
good angle for in Ghana right here.
Oh right.
Watch this watch has head move. Ooh. And
then he got clipped and that's what I,
that's why came. Did it address that? And
he goes, I got too close too. So he's too,
when you,
when you think about a person that might
be like 41 pounds on the cocaine party
where you're saying you think about
a person like he, you know, he's,
he's essentially like optimize
their to 65 or he's optimized.
He's like a of real through 65
CC's for five rounds of July,
z optimized. Well here's
the thing though, he,
all he has to do is get better at that
first round and do you really think a lot
of guys are going to make it
into their second or third?
They've just played it in slow
motion. Oh fuck. I missed this angle.
It looks like you missed this and I
don't really know. He shovel who know us.
Can we hold on, hold on. Hold on.
Slow motion. I clipped him there.
Right kind. Hundred percent. That's clips.
That's 100% says that
you see his head move.
That's why king throws a single leg
on the ref cause he's concussed.
He went for the single friends. This
is the scariest of all time. Guys win.
Oh fall time over ubering dude.
The thing about Francis,
his speed,
he's he,
he's learning at this
like really rapid rate.
When you look at a guy that's only
been doing it for how many years now?
100% trained. He's been fighting
for like maybe five years,
I think five years from the
time he learns martial arts.
His Dad was some legendary fights.
He was doing this with saying, dude,
he's a movie character. If he can
just get over the hump that he got,
look the steep, pay me. Oh, chicks fight.
That's, that's what's up man. I mean,
he got to the top of the mount
dude. He's a funny guy. DC now.
Revenger boy.